did you know that the Dragon Ball super
movie that you have at home is not
actually how it looked in theaters
that's right the home release version of
both Dragon Ball super Broly and Dragon
Ball super super hero were released with
accidentally messed up colors to this
day they are still printed with a green
tint all over the movies for some reason
it can sometimes be a little more subtle
but in certain scenes it is very obvious
that someone peed green all over these
Blu-rays currently there is no official
way to watch these movies at home the
way that they were supposed to look and
the worst part is this isn't even a
creative choice on toei's part it's pure
accident though maybe I'll get into that
another day